being a senator was a great job I bet I
loved being a senator and it was you
know it was a job that I loved
representing New York I and then I was
there to God you know I took office
early January and then on September 11th
we were attacked so that became my job I
mean my job was to help rebuild the city
help protect people help rebuild their
lives did a good job
well it was an it was an incredible
honor don't something else Rankin thing
break your heart I think he was a fan
tatted you did you serve it all with him
and this no no but but he did a really
good job in that guy good job not a
lawyer but because he wasn't one really
wanted to understand policies I felt he
worked really hard exactly huh he really
did who is the best president in your
opinion but beside you let's take your
husband out of it when you go through
history who is the best president that
ever served Lincoln see I think
Washington why do you think Lincoln well
it would be close I mean it would be
like one degree difference between
Washington and Lincoln because they both
first of all they were they understood
the job right and they both exercised
thoughtful disciplined approaches to the
job George Washington said don't make me
your king they want them to make inque
they wanted to make him King and then he
quit after two terms right and then he
gave a great speech which people should
be reading every week about avoiding
factions meaning partisanship and you
know putting country over party and all
of that melody that's gone out the
window but I think I mean Washington it
turned out Washington was actually a
really good general and won the
Revolutionary War deserves a lot of
credit for that but I think Lincoln I
place him and it's very slightly ahead
of Washington because I think Lincoln
faced the worst possible choices you
know Washington was in the creative mode
like we're gonna build this country I've
got smart people around me
that's what other reason I've seen
Hamilton four times I mean I just loved
everything about that and Linc
if you there's some great works about
him that are really worth diving into my
friend Sid Blumenthal has a great now
4-volume life of Lincoln focusing on his
political life so you read it yeah it's
it's really good and it I gotta read it
has stuff that other people haven't it's
really but what the point of it is that
you know he had this view that he had to
save the Union and how do you save the
Union when it's a free and a half slave
and and what are the compromises you're
willing to make and then finally
concluded if you know we can't we can't
stay the United States with slavery you
can't it cannot work and that lives
heartbreaking to him I mean you you look
at the way that he just got older and
older more burden broken down living
with the incredible responsibilities he
had that can you imagine the
responsibility this guy had the whole
United States was at war I mean yeah and
it was such a brutal war I mean what
700,000 people killed so crazy yeah you
know it's a great movie I just saw bill
and I went to the movie talked about us
sneaking out we went to see Harriet the
Harriet Tubman story good good good and
very uh I thought you know very true I
mean you know some liberties for being a
movie but mostly a really good fair
retelling of this amazing woman story
she's in our book did you see mr. right
yes I got it wait I haven't got today I
don't want to run out of time but mr.
Rogers did you see they haven't seen it
yet but I was going to oh did you like
mr. Rogers when you were growing no I I
wasn't I was Soupy Sales I was much you
know I'm an older guy you know that was
my that was my Mister Rogers
it was demented you know but because you
didn't have mr. Rogers growing up no we
didn't have that I was I was growing I
was pretty much grown up by that my kids
would watch mr. Rogers and they were
very bored by him because in that in the
fast-paced movement of television this
guy was so slow paced but when you see
this movie you just fall in love with
this guy he is so great and so empathic
I mean was just amazed
you know I read a piece the other day
where a woman who had watched it but
also felt like you know what's the big
deal I mean I wasn't that interesting so
she decided maybe she was writing a
review of it or something but she
decided she would watch old versions of
it and all of a sudden she has these
young kids I wasn't they come in and
they start watching it and she made a
really astute observation she said you
know in this fast-paced world it was
like my kids just exhaled and they were
in front of that TV set watching this
gentle man talk to them about being kind
and taking care of each other and they
loved it oh it was so beautiful I didn't
have any idea of what this guy was and I
bet Tom Hanks was perfect Tom Hanks is
brilliant in it so get back to the great
love affair because we think you know I
mean he's working his magic on you
you've gotta be swooning at this point
because he just got you into I mean
you're by the way I think it's
interesting that you enjoyed growing up
the comic um Brenda Starr yes I read it
too I loved it it was great I mean the
ride was the only woman if you're a
woman and you want a woman comic Wonder
Woman in yeah and Brenda Starr that's
right
and and she was so romantic remember
when she was dating the pirate so so
bill is hitting all the right notes
yeah he's hitting all the right notes
and so then okay so then we do go on a
formal day we go out to dinner and
there's money to take you out to dinner
well it was it was cheap in those days I
mean you know no Chinese food yeah but
then I really didn't know kiss at this
point well we got there eventually not
at the Museum not at the museum I would
have kissed them at the Museum no no no
now that's a museum well you know I was
just getting to know my dad you know in
those days we we did play a little hard
to get
so get you in the museum Eric meanwhile
I still have a boyfriend
oh yes back home know this from college
from college yeah I met him while you
were at Wellesley I met him while I was
at Wellesley yes how long had you been
seeing this guy I'd been seeing him by
that time about two years did you feel
guilty what AG with Bill I felt I didn't
feel guilty yet you haven't done
anything had done anything and I also
thought well you know he's really
interesting and you know maybe this goes
somewhere maybe it doesn't but we'll see
but I still had a boyfriend and so did
you love this boyfriend mm-hmm you did
mm-hmm
look at you I did who know all this look
what was going on and law school and at
the same time well listen you were a
catch well I don't know about that
burning power this guy my boyfriend yes
was a conscientious objector ah did you
have to go to jail no he he was accepted
as a conscientious objector right and he
had to do alternative service and his
alternative service started off in
Alabama and then he was transferred to
Vermont [ __ ] bath sir so he couldn't be
with his love well I visited him when he
was in Alabama and then building up and
then when he moved to Vermont
yes so I would go see him
on the weekends I bought an old
Oldsmobile Cutlass that was the most
temperamental car I've ever owned I paid
about $150 for it and for some reason it
it would it would just freeze every day
and and it just you know I'd had to get
it jumped all the time I was a terrible
time with it so I used to take you know
I used to take it up to Vermont I would
go up to see my boyfriend but it would
oftentimes stop and I you know it was a
really a messy car right but anyway we
were kind of winding down at that point
you have a facebook this guy to see how
he looks my guide he died I can see how
you know that you always look below I
went to the funeral you did I did
did he contact you after you hooked up
with bill we would occasionally be in
communication yeah really he was a
really great bill hey listen what are
you doing
well no bill um really thought he was
terrific he was he was really yeah he
was a terrific guy he was a great
athlete he and I would go skiing
together we would go hiking together he
was a great athlete was he heartbroken
when you said you when you announced to
him listen I uh with the beard
I I don't know I think I think that we
were we were sort of moving apart and
bill just kind of was the the reason at
the end would he ever say to you over
the years would you keep tabs on him if
he was married this guy and all this
other stuff I knew he was oh you know
yeah how did I just liked him he was a
good guy oh he must have been so upset
he was any was so handsome he was really
really really handsome yeah he looks
like a Greek god he was really handsome
no kidding Greek god yeah
he's very attractive well I'd listen to
you
well contrary to what you may hear I
actually like men oh yeah you have
strong relationships with women
friendship do guys can pal around all
they want and that doesn't cause that
but when women do it all of a sudden
there might be something to everything
we do apparently so getting to the love
affair yes okay so so here's what
happened so I was going to have a party
in my dorm room for the end of the year
okay right and my roommate night and so
we had this party and a lot of people
came in and out you know hors d'oeuvres
beer whatever and so bill came and so it
was really the first time I'd seen him
since we went to the museum why so long
between the museum and this part days
what did that one wasn't okay all right
all right all right yeah
and so and then and and so he just
started you know and so he stayed and so
everybody left and we just started
talking and we talked and we talked and
we talked and we talked practically all
night and it was great Wow yeah and then
about a day later I got sick I got a
cold or something so we were supposed to
go out and I called him remember those
old phones remember phones I called him
I said you know I don't feel good he
comes over he brings me orange juice
chicken soup I mean yeah it was great so
we started going out right and and you
dumped this discreet God we we we broke
up
obviously right was gonna call them or
you went to see him you did yeah I did
honorable well yeah look at you I expect
to be treated that way so why would a
nitrous drove all the way wherever this
conscientious objector was and you the
Vermont and you said listen I've met a
guy and he said I am a Greek god what
are you doing now we we were beginning
to sort of separate before bill but
anyway it was very nice that you did
that well he was a good guy right so
anyway we we started dating and we did
date and date and date and then we
graduated in 1973 and we went he took me
to England and France because he loved
being there when he was a Rhodes Scholar
so we traveled all over and we ended up
in the lake country and this was June of
73 and that was the first time he asked
me to marry him and I said I'm not ready
to get married because you hadn't even
started your law career yeah yeah no I
was gonna go to work for the Children's
Defense Fund that that was my my passion
that's why he would have anything kids
that's why he would have been a good
president who gets out of Yale and then
defense children everyone's out to make
the big corporate buck right there's a
good tradition but 99% of them all but
the woman I was working for Marian
Wright Edelman had gone to Yale Law
School and so she had formed this
Children's Defense Fund she was she is
an incredible human being and had been
the first black woman ever to pass the
Mississippi bar
acknowledged so I mean I admired her
really was you know and feeling great
about working for some rejected bills
proposal his first proposal is and then
this is so ironic so then I'm visiting
him over Christmas end of 1973 beginning
of 1974 he gets a phone call and the
phone call is from a lawyer named John
doar and John doar says to bill I've
just been hired to head up the
impeachment inquiry staff investigating
Richard Nixon and I've got the name of
five young lawyers from Yale that I
would like to hire to be part of this
and and I'm calling you to ask if you
would be and bill said no I'm gonna run
for Congress and then bill says well who
else is on the list and he told him and
my name was on the list so bill said
well Hillary Rodham is right here so
hands me the phone
and John doar says how'd you like to
come to Washington and yeah yeah so I
went to Washington by the way how
interesting is it that the Trump things
going you know you got to hand it to
Trump though he's handling impeachment
imagine if Nixon had it wasn't just said
screw you all yeah yeah I don't think I
think Nixon would have actually survived
and remain president if he handled it
the way Trump tries like I'm denying
denying denying it was a different time
and you had Republicans who followed the
law that's right so what happened with
that case because I was on it from early
January until he did resign you know it
was really important that we not make
any preconceptions just look at the
evidence
so you weren't sitting there going
Nixon's guilty I wasn't I wasn't not
well and it was Nixon was not a horrible
president would you agree with that
statement
I would Nixon did some good things he
did darn right you know people don't
remember he started the Environmental
Protection Agency for goodness sakes I
do know that you know yes and and and he
opened the door to China yes I mean he
he was a Republican of a different era
right his paranoia his personal
personal nightmare he was he was so
paranoid he was he was he had that
election won he didn't have to go
breaking in anywhere I think he got the
biggest electoral victory in the history
of the country but he did he got and and
the people around him and that's why
it's really important you have you have
not only good smart people around you
but people who will tell you not to do
things or will contradict you and
question you and of course Nixon you
know got to the point where he was being
surrounded by yes men right and so when
the evidence began to come out and the
grand jury the Senate Select Committee
all of that so in June of 74 I'm one of
the young lawyers in a soundproof room
with headphones on listening to the
tapes that had finally been turned over
because you know the court said you had
to turn him over right so when we went
to the impeachment articles which is
kind of the phase that this Congress is
getting to everybody knew we we were and
Peter Rodino who was chairing the
Judiciary Committee was also very
discreet like we you know we don't know
where it's gonna turn out we're just
getting gathering the evidence but when
you saw the evidence it was pretty
compelling that he abused power
obstructed justice he'd maybe what amped
up Congress what a life you have I mean
the fact that you get out of Yale yeah
and now you're you're actually
investigating the president United yeah
you know what else is weird too I was
thinking about this I always see that
film of when when your husband was a
little boy he got to shake hands with
John F Kennedy did you when you were in
high school you get to meet Martin
Luther King and kind of like be in a
room with him I got to shake hands with
you that's a very little-known fact
right like how did I get to meet Martin
Luther King when you're when you're a
young lady I'll tell you why because of
my church oh so I had a youth minister
who was determined that in my little
white suburb in my all-white church that
we were gonna know there was a world
bigger and that we had to understand how
other people lived and thought I mean
the guy was amazing he's been the most
influential people in my growing up so
he says to us one day we would have a
youth fellowship on Sunday nights he
says you know
dr. Martin Luther King jr. is coming to
Chicago I would like to take our
fellowship group to Chicago to hear him
speak well you have to get your parents
permission of course
some of the parents wouldn't how old are
you at this point I'm 13 probably 13 14
your parents said okay God my parents
have absolutely yeah how do you get to
meet him well you go and you hear he
gave a sermon called staying awake
during the revolution and then he stood
up there and if you wanted to meet him
you stood in line and we stood in lines
for probably an hour and then we got to
shake his hand so crazy here your future
husband who becomes president I'd say
he's got to meet China of kitty you're
hanging out with Martin Luther King
charm but you know it was also because
of where we put ourselves when we were
interested in these people I was never
interested in going into politics when I
was a young woman never God when I would
I was so dopey I never took advantage of
any of these music I ran comic books but
well but and it helped you it's worked
out pretty well yeah so so you know I
would imagine you see here's the other
thing too so let's let's fast-forward a
bit yeah bill becomes I'm calling bill
like I know but bill becomes a governor
of Arkansas you marry him you become the
first lady of Arkansas right again it's
like I I think about your expertise your
your education I would think like being
the first lady of Arkansas sure it's
nice but it's not enough in the sense
that it's almost wasting who you are I
disagree with that and here's here's why
it might have been in the past or it
might have been for other people but I
was practicing law I was also starting
organizations like something called the
Arkansas advocates for children families
I was always deeply committed maybe
because of my mom's own life and so you
didn't look at it as like a second
it was all I tried to have an integrated
life look at Bill and go you know
because he has a penis he gets to be the
governor and I'm the first lady I could
be the government no I never thought
that Haley no Dan never thought no not a
not a smidgen because well I thought he
would do what he was doing and I would
do now I did make a what it turned out
to be quite a big miscalculation and
that was this so we get married in 1975
and I'm gonna keep my name hillary
rodham right and i'm doing it both
because you know it's my name and I'm
also doing it because I'm practicing law
and I thought okay I don't want there to
be any thought that I'm trading off of
him you know all that stuff if you use
the name clay and you're at a law firm
and then yeah I'm really trying hard not
to let any of that and be thought and so
I have to avoid conflicts whatever so I
do this and it becomes a huge issue
I mean backfire its backfires because
like you know it was 1975 and then
Chelsea's born in 1980 so the the
picture on the front page of the paper
is Governor Bill Clinton and Hillary
Rodham the birth of their daughter do
you think it was that the press is
saying in some snide way look at this
guy he can't get his woman under control
some of that there was some of that
right some of it was it was just who
does she think she is you know that's
not what we do down here or anywhere but
women we're making a statement in those
years hey maintain my identity were
trying to but it became such a
distraction and I said okay fine well
add Clinton to Hillary Rodham Clinton by
the time your husband becomes president
right and again you're the first lady
right do you still have that same view
are you starting to say you know I've
got the skills to be a president is it
starting to percolate no and I'll again
I'll tell you what first of all when I
was in Arkansas I headed I headed a
commission to revamp the education
system I also worked on improving health
care particularly for you know poor
women so I I felt like I was doing good
work and that's really what motivates me
so I did that so we get to Washington
and this was another big les
so bill says to me you know if we don't
do something about health care people
are uninsured
it's the costs are exploding we're not
even taking care of everybody I want to
really do a big push to reform health
care do you want to be involved I say
sure yeah I remember that and I was
proud of you and very excited by this
and yet I can you caught crap for this
totally because again the Hillary care
was was a negative it was like oh look
at her I mean people were burning me in
effigy and so like you were a communist
yeah exactly and it was a you know we
had a plan and the plan was to mold an
employer mandate with an individual
mandate which is what eventually
happened with the Affordable Care Act
under Obama but it was so funny because
when I had done education reform in
Arkansas and it was controversial we
made some tough decisions you know
people were like well thank you for
helping you know we're really glad
you're involved and all that get to
Washington and it turns out to be a more
conservative place when it comes to what
a first lady can do and so it became who
is the great take yourself out of the
running right and initialize him in your
book right gutsy women who is the
greatest First Lady Eleanor Roosevelt
Eleanor why hardly because she was her
husband's eyes ears and legs right
she literally traveled the world she
would bring back information for him she
also pushed him sometimes successfully
often not successfully she pushed him
really hard on civil rights she pushed
him on you know trying to open the doors
to more Jews fleeing Europe would you
look at Eleanor Roosevelt when you
became first lady and say hey I got it I
got to somehow live up to that standard
absolutely and then when something like
Hillary Care backfires on you do you go
why can't I be white why can't I be a
little Roosevelt is it just frustrating
no because she never took a formal
position she was smarter than me
everything she did was informal behind
the scenes or she would in or she was a
prolific writer she wrote a newspaper
column a day for years she wrote lots of
books so but but she understood and and
frankly her husband FDR understood you
know
get into the formal mix and so what she
did was both symbolic and and effective
the way that she conductors when you
became first lady did you ever pick up
the phone and call any former first lady
oh my gosh yes you did
absolutely how does that go well I'll
tell you I mean I like a Rosalyn Carter
no I mean first of all I think every one
of these women have done something that
I can admire and I talk about right but
I had a great meeting with Jackie
Kennedy where did you do that at her
apartment on Fifth Avenue was it a
spectacular apartment it was it was it
was homey I mean it was you know it was
beautiful and comfortable and filled
with books and flowers you picked up the
phone and said she read so she supported
bill right and so I met her you know
during that time period but once Bill
was elected I mean it's just such an
abrupt change and everything you've ever
done you know you don't drive your own
car you you know can't go out alone
things you were talking about before is
it is it a rush it's a rush but it's an
adjustment I mean it's it you know the
rush wears off and and and the and the
confinement continues right but I went
so she asked me to if to come see her so
I I went to see her it was so great
because you know what she was really
focused on was how to make the white
house at home for our daughter and she
talked about what she had done and how
she had raised you know John yeah it and
and she was funny
even she was an incredibly gracious
smart witty was that hard for you to
negotiate with Chelsea in terms of that
no no no well she was heartbroken to
leave Arkansas I mean that was where she
was born where she was raised where she
went to school and there were a lot of
tough issues like where did she go to
school and I here's what I learned from
the Carters whom I admire deeply they
put Amy who was their only one stolen
home into public school which would have
been my preference because Chelsea had
gone to public schools in Little Rock
but the press wouldn't leave the school
alone so the first day this little girl
goes out to the playground it's like
you know paparazzi climbing the fences
walking onto the playground because it
was public isn't that unbelievable that
they do it's the one place they gotta
back off back off from kids and and you
know my daughter has a great Twitter
presence and she defends Barron Trump
you know all the time anybody anything
about him you know that I've saw someone
the other day saying that Melania is
such an attack personally you were the
most attacked first lady were you not I
mean
Kalani's got it easier compared to well
but part of it because of what I was
trying to do right starting with health
care she never picked up the phone and
called you have been asked for advice to
be first lady did she know she wouldn't
know the guy I hate I had you're the
villain well yeah because I beat him if
you count the votes but anyway but I had
great conversations with Barbara Bush
Laura Bush Rosalyn Carter Michelle Obama
we trade it and and we would go to
things you know library opening some
kind of you know presidential or first
lady's events I also was very admiring
of Lady Bird Johnson I didn't get to
know Pat Nixon particularly well but I
really admired Betty Ford and put her in
the book I put her in the book because
he admitted to her alcoholism and
because of what she did for breast
cancer right my mother's best friend who
lived across the street from us was sick
but nobody would say the words breast
cancer that was taboo it was almost like
the AIDS virus like what people were
afraid to say they had cancer like you'd
catch it I know and in breast you didn't
say the word breast cancer and so I my
mother would go over to see her friend
Eleanor every day and Eleanor died and
then along comes Betty Ford she's in the
White House her husband's the president
after Nixon's resignation she gets
breast cancer she gets she was a
beautiful woman she gets herself dressed
up in the bed in the hospital after her
treatment gets her husband there has the
photographer's come in she starts
talking about breast cancer she saved
lives Howard then fast forward she
admits he's got an addiction problem and
she starts the Betty Ford Center you're
so right about this and you see we
forget this is why it's important to
write books and remem
her history important history because
even you know I had this thing with my
kidney I wrote about in my book I was
ashamed I didn't want I there was a
bunch of reason but I didn't want to
talk about my own I didn't want it to be
an issue this and that for her to be
first lady at that time write and say
breast cancer right and I'm addicted
right insane and I bet you she got a lot
of pressure from her husband not to do
that well you know to his credit because
there's a there's a new autobiography of
her out that it's very detailed by the
way he was not a bad President Gerald
Ford was pretty good I always liked him
me too I liked him and you know I know
that it was really controversial and it
probably did hurt him when he ran
against President Carter in 76 that he
pardoned Nixon but Nix had been punished
he'd been forced to resign because
Republicans went to him yes in
retrospect it it got rid of the issue it
like I did off the play it allowed the
country to move on Nixon did in my view
the right thing by resigning
so when to but but when they had the
stage in intervention
over her addictions and it was tough
because at by that time she was a former
first lady but still in the public eye
how embarrassing
she had to go somewhere for treatment
her first treatment was at a military
facility pretty bare-bones but the
family stood by her they were unashamed
and and that's the kind of courage you
know really can make a difference in
somebody else's life because now people
Betty Ford took me through the Betty
Ford Center and showed me around yeah
and what about when Michael Dukakis Rand
yes his wife admitted to having a
problem I don't think she would have
done that if it wasn't for Gerald Ford
yes right it all leads up to something
and now people are willing people are
much more willing and much more open I
know yeah yeah I mean and even
especially when you run for president I
remember when you had that fainting
spell or whatever it was they had you
dead they had me dead well you know so
what happened I hadn't been feeling good
but and finally so my my doctor this was
on Friday she says you know well let's
get an x-ray oh my gosh you happen
ammonia so here are the antibiotics
knock it out okay so I do my schedule
Friday I do my schedule Saturday and
Sunday is you know the 15th anniversary
of nine
and I have really strong feelings about
that right so I decided I'm gonna go a
mistake here's a funny little aside so I
get to the site we go to down to the the
site down downtown and Chuck Schumer
meets me and Schumer says because I
served with Chuck as you know do you
like Chuck I do I do I think he's an
incredibly hard worker
but he was too hard on Al Franken right
I you know come on I wish that it turned
out differently let me say that okay I
really do I think that there should have
been a process right so anyway so Chuck
meets min he goes off so glad to see you
you know I've had pneumonia I've been in
the house for five days first time I've
been out I thought wow this is weird
yeah and so there I am at the ceremony
and I start to feel you know kind of
weak so I said okay I better leave so I
walk I get to the car and that's when I
thought okay I'm really gonna faint I
get in the car fine I was fine I go to
my daughter's apartment I rest up for
about an hour then I come out the press
is there they see me I'm not dead and I
say okay you know good to see you guys I
go on with my schedule you would have
thought that I was being in the cemetery
yeah absolutely it was crazy
have you gotten your pneumonia vaccine
yes I did just sorta died yes I didn't
your arm killing you yes it was I
couldn't lift my arm I thought it was
done you down your shingles yes from the
shingles vaccine no I didn't I had three
days of misery I'm so glad I got it you
know every time I hear about somebody
with shingles I go please my wife and
English raised about people who don't
vaccinate yes this is nuts and people
are dying yes and and anyone's anti
science well what is the problem I don't
get it
well they think the autism is being
called has been debunked continuously
doesn't matter anymore yeah I guess not
no but I'm believing while they're
putting their kids but more importantly
everybody else's kids at risk